did you get the wire out the red wire
no no you're going to plug that red wire
where the blue wire goes in the board
now put the red one no don't don't put
the blue one back
but be careful they're oppositely
charged
no hold them apart
so how'd you like to go back to navarro
has mando been taking good care of you
huh have you been taking good care of
him
yeah yeah he said yeah yeah
from the outer rim to as far away
as the court world however
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
yes hang on kid
[Music]
[Music]
not too bad huh kid
oh boy
what did i say about that
this needs to stay in the ship
we need to talk i hope it's about him
grogo and i can feel each other's
thoughts kroger
yes
[Music]
someone took him from the temple then
his memory becomes
dark he seemed
lost
let's see what knowledge is lurking
inside that little mind
now return the stone to me groga
grogu come on
take the stone you see
i told you he's stubborn try to connect
with him
kroger
do you want this come on you can have it
good job good job kid
grogu
groga
grogu come on you can have it
thank you
hey no i'm not mad at you you did good
you're very special kid
don't you want to learn more of that
jedi stuff
this is the seeing stone are you seeing
anything
[Music]
time's up kid we gotta get out of here
we gotta get
okay i'm gonna protect you just stay
[Music]
there
[Music]
have you ever seen one of these
[Music]
that they've killed everyone on the
bridge being the
murderous savages that they are
they're beginning to panic
i'll see you again
[Music]
[Music]
may the force be with you
you